When I take an image
[shutter click]
music just plays in my head.
I don't know if that works
for everyone else,
but that's just how it works
for me.
I sound crazy,
but it's the honest truth.
[uplifting piano music]
The thing about photography
that I particularly love
is just being able
to like,
capture a moment
[shutter click]
and then other people
will be able
to feel exactly what you felt
when you took the picture.
[talking and camera sounds]
I like this because it's
kind of like a perspective
of what you probably do
when there's nobody here.
(Sarah)
I feel like photography
allows me to show
the beautiful side of New Haven
as well as the real side
that other people need to see
to make all of it beautiful.
I used to attend Achievement
First Amistad High on Dixwell.
I'm 18 years old,
and I love photography.
This one's my favorite
The thing with Amistad
is that at Amistad
it's a college prep school,
so they don't really focus
particularly on the arts
programs.
So as far as a photography club
or a photography class,
there was nothing of the sort
so I was really kind
of frustrated
to not be able to have a space
to share with other kids
and other colleagues
and other people
in the community of our skills
and our artistic sides.
[traffic sounds]
[soft music]
(Martina)
I think I've become more aware
of the role that the museum
could play in the community
and that we actually need to
come out and be more proactive
in what we offer
to people that feels
relevant to them
and that feels like
a point of connection.
The View From Here began
because I was curating
an exhibition
with Paul Messier at the
Institute for the Preservation
of Cultural Heritage
about the artist Bill Brandt
and the artist Henry Moore
and how they came together
through photography.
(Sarah)
My counselor was like: hey,
there's this photography program
that Yale is throwing
and they're interested
in some students
and you know, you should apply.
(Martina)
We opened a competitive
application system
where we invited students
who are enrolled in
what we called
greater New Haven.
High school students
and first year college students
and we thought we might get
a mix of people who are
at that point in their lives
where they're thinking about
what they want to do.
(Sarah)
I applied, I got an email
a couple days later saying
that we saw your application
and we would like
to interview you
to be a part of the internship
and I was shocked
because I didn't do this
seriously,
because I didn't think
I'd be called back.
We had a really good response
to the call for applications
from a huge variety of schools
in the greater New Haven area.
It was exactly
what we hoped for.
It was like a roller coaster
of emotions.
It was like from I'm not
taking this seriously
to I'm super excited that
I actually got into the program
and then from there,
it was just a great time.
Hi, Sarah.
[Zoom bell sound]
Hi Bob! How's it going?
(Sarah)
I absolutely love
all of the instructors there.
I absolutely love Bob Hixon.
Sarah was very impressive,
as a person
and also her photography.
(Sarah)
I think this was shot at
the lowest that my lens can go.
I have a 1.4 lens.
So I was like, let me experiment
with that aperture.
This is one of my favorites
that you did this year.
(Bob)
Sometimes they taught me
when it comes
to content
and meaning and story.
They were very good
with telling stories
in their photographs,
which is something that
that I admire and
I'm not always very good at it.
(Sarah)
With Bob, on the outside
he can seem, you know,
intimidating and very serious
but I got to see the artistic,
you know, emotional,
sentimental side of him
that allowed me
to be more comfortable with
reaching out to him as well.
(Martina)
The process for
gathering our team
that was teaching the course was
I mean in a way,
it sort of mirrored
the process of thinking
about what we want to do
for the community.
What's our own community here
within the museum?
We have photographers,
you know, who've been
practicing photography
for years, decades.
So we wanted to bring them in as
they're experts in photography.
That background.
That's a dynamite
treatment there.
(Bob)
Teaching on behalf of Yale
can be a little daunting.
Thank you! I really
appreciate that!
But her reaction filled me
with confidence
that alright,
I can do this, she's connecting.
Ever since the program started
I've been just
dreaming of the day
that we'll
all be able to meet up.
It would be really cool
to see the people
that had that impact on me
and that gave me the opportunity
to venture out
on my photography side
when I didn't
have the opportunity
to do that in school.
[Bright synth music]
(Martina)
I'm so excited
for this exhibition.
We're going
to invite the students
to come to a meet and greet,
a private viewing
of the exhibition in person.
So we'll meet them in person
for the first time.
It's really amazing to
see you. You look wonderful.
Oh so do you!
Thank you!
[upbeat synth music]
[laughing]
Yo! This is crazy!
It's good right?
(Bob)
You know, after dark
to see these beautiful images
projected into the windows,
I hope that they are
all thrilled when they
see their work there.
It looks amazing.
Like absolutely stunning.
Well, we appreciate the trust
you put in us because,
you know, it was an experiment
for us as well.
Oh, hi, Bob.
oh here's Bob!
I would hug you if I could.
I know! Elbow!
How's it going?
It's been such a long time.
It's been a minute
since we've spoken.
Yeah!
You're also very tall, too.
I didn't think you're going
to be this tall.
Yeah!
[laughing]
It's just nice to see that we
get our work somewhere.
(Sarah)
The way that we're
able to communicate
and look at our pictures
as if we did all this in person
is I guess it speaks
to the experience of
photography and art.
Like, although we did it
online, we're here in person,
and the feelings are natural
and it's just great.
I think it's amazing.
(Martina)
I hope that the students
will take away from this course,
a sense of self-confidence
in their own artistic abilities,
their own artistic discernment
and I know from conversations
that I've had with some
of the students that they see
photography differently now.
(Bob)
These students, Sarah
and the others
have so much going on,
are so capable in many ways
that I think they're all
destined to do great things.
If I had a little bit to do
with that, that's great.
Congratulations to you!
[clapping and cheering]
(Sarah)
I will definitely remember
this moment in my life
as life changing,
and not to be melodramatic,
but in all honesty,
it did change my life.
To think that my pictures,
somebody from New Haven,
somebody who goes to a
charter school down the street
has the ability
to have their pictures
on the building.
It's a very emotional feeling.
It's very, it makes me happy
and makes me proud
and it makes me
feel accomplished.
[upbeat synth music]
♪♪